when you think of the modeling industry
the first thing you think of is skinny
people I'm sorry I'm just going to say
it I see more and more models or plus
size there's a huge Market that's being
open to that still when I look at a
billboard I see a skinny person
[Music]
step forward if you agree with the
prompt
models are not good role models for teen
girls
I'm not going to say all models aren't
good for Role Models but I think when
teen girls especially are looking up to
models who look a certain way who are
super skinny it's going to make them
maybe think well if I want to be like
this person I need to look like this
person I need to be what this person is
so it can be harming to them it can be a
disadvantage yeah when you're a middle
school girl or a high schooler and you
see that your body is different from the
models like you don't know how they
achieve that and so I think it can
contribute to like eating disorder
culture just a lot of insecurity within
girls not because things that the models
are explicitly saying or doing but just
because when girls look at models they
kind of just see the ways that they
would have to attain those body types
and so that's what kind of negatively
affects them for me I think it's less
about the individual person the
collective group of just models in
general are complicit in a system that
harms women especially young girls one
thing most women have in common is that
they've seen a magazine once in their
life they've seen an Instagram they have
experience some form of the modeling
industry's content and then
subconsciously begin to condition their
brain to think that is who I have to be
and that I am less than if I am not that
thing I also think that it's not really
models themselves who are like really
the bad influence I just think it's the
industry and the people who are
enforcing these standards and kind of
like the male gaze and the sexualization
of these women I agree I think that the
the industry is really the the biggest
problem and the biggest threat to
teenage girls just because they have a
set standard for what they want to see
but aren't models still complicit in
that industry just by doing their job
yeah I agree with that as well but I
also think that the biggest problem is
the industry's idea of what a model
needs to be and what it needs to look
like and but it also comes from the
models who are putting themselves in
this position which is definitely their
choice but it could also cause teenage
girls to think of themselves differently
in the disagree a step forward
so I would say I do understand your
opinion however I would also say there's
not only the modeling industry that said
the beauty standards you have a lot of
actors athletes that represent these
beauty standards in a way that I've
chosen to represent Brands I don't think
we hold the whole the entire
responsibility of the beauty standards
that are set because in a way I did not
choose the beauty standard I never
started this job thinking oh I'm gonna
consciously harm younger women but I do
understand what cheerleaders are saying
you know I feel like nowadays we have a
social media platform which can be used
for harm or for good and I think a lot
of models nowadays there's
um kind of an insight to the industry
about Photoshop about retouching about
all this stuff and I think a lot of
models are being honest about it and
letting the general public know that
this is not real this is like these
people Photoshop this or this is how my
skin actually looks and I think if more
models take that stand and actually
embody our imperfections I think in that
way models can be very good role models
for team but I know that's not always
what has been happening and what history
has shown but I think as models we have
the responsibility to do that as well
nowadays I'm thinking about Collective
harm versus Collective good and the
amount of models who are actually trying
to remove the veil on what goes on and
show that this isn't real they're far
fewer of the of the good ones than the
ones like Kim Kardashian who said The
only reason I look like this is because
I eat well I think also just knowing
that like people are editing their
photos it doesn't give the best message
to girls knowing that there is editing
going on because then you're thinking oh
wait but then I should be editing my own
photo like I should be photoshopping my
own photo to look better to look
different to look like these models so I
feel like we instantly go to answer the
question is the modeling industry good
that wasn't the question so I feel like
people compare themselves to models but
they don't understand that their primary
role is to sell a product or to sell a
service so they're not saying hey
everyone this is how you should look a
lot of times it's like hey everyone this
is what lip gloss you should probably be
wearing you know so when I see
Billboards and when I see ads I'm like
why do they choose her what's different
about her and I don't automatically
result to how she looks I start looking
into branding and marketing and hopes
that it's not performative and it's not
just to check off we have a black girl
we have a plus size but that it's the
latter and that they actually do care
about people so I feel like we should go
into that a little bit more I think that
you have that perspective as a model and
as someone who's been involved in the
industry I just think that from an
outside perspective and for young girls
they kind of immediately categorize
these people as oh this is what I should
look like this is the standard so when
you all see ads do you instantly only
think about how they look or do you try
to find out who the person is and like
do research on the brand how they align
it's definitely a comparison that comes
to my mind when I think of seeing ads
Billboards even just magazines Etc I'm I
tend to compare myself to these models a
lot it's embedded in my mind at this
point because I've heard it even from a
young age even a minute on the lips
Forever on the hips I feel like that's
like something I was taught at a young
age which is like so toxic and even from
TV shows you know there was always a
standard that you have to look a certain
way
I think when I feel I don't love my body
it normally comes from this feeling of I
guess I want to be good enough I want to
have this privilege this ideal I guess
and this standard that's set in our
society and especially in LA and I just
try to remind myself of what I am
capable of and my intelligence and my
kindness Etc hi this is ragni the
director of this episode if you enjoy
watching Middle Ground please like this
video And subscribe to our Channel now
let's get back to the video
beauty pageants should be discontinued
at their core beauty pageants are women
competing with other women and the thing
that they are using as competition is
looks so it goes back to at a certain
age when anyone looks at us especially
men they don't see our hopes our dreams
our goals what we want to be they see
how we look I also agreed I think they
should be discontinued because you see
Teen pageants like you see all these 15
16 year old girls walking down the
runway in their little bikinis and
they're showing it to everybody but it's
like when you kind of think about it who
owns these companies it used to be owned
by Donald Trump like you know that's
kind of makes it a little weird if you
think about it and like why are we
actually doing this you know I agree I
mean I'm not very educated I would say
on this topic as much as I would like to
be so I'm learning a lot more from you
guys but there are like pageants for
six-year-old girls who are going out
yeah the toddler like toddler tiaras
whatever and they're going out at like
with full faces of makeup and they would
get like spray tans and all this stuff
at like six years old and I was just
like they're growing up with this it's I
think it's very harmful for these young
girls especially because they think they
need to fit into look a certain way for
their entire lives
foreign
I would personally say that I don't see
any harm in beauty pageants if it's done
with adults over 18. I am totally
against beauty pageant for younger women
or younger teenagers and children
however I do think that it can give some
opportunities I started my career as a
model by winning a beauty pageant was
like American like friends text that
bottle basically so if it wasn't for
that I would not have the career I have
today if it's done in the right way and
at a certain age where you are a woman
and not a child then I think it's okay I
also compete in pageants I'll be
competing for Miss California USA next
month and I feel like they're very
misunderstood because it is not just
about beauty a lot of the women are just
very well-rounded there's so many
different phases of the competition
there's interview there's you know so
many women who are big on philanthropy
and then I think that it is good for
teens to do as well because they're
being introduced to something that they
may or may not be interested in but
there are also so many different
procedures that are being put in place
to where actually the teens are in
active wear gear now they're not wearing
swimsuits on stage so I don't feel like
they should be discontinued I think that
they need to continue to go through this
period of refinement yeah I would agree
I think a lot of girls look forward to
participating in them and not because of
the toxic nature that people might
assume surrounds it but just because it
showcases a lot of things there are a
lot of the times asked questions about
the world and have to have public
speaking skills and a lot of time
there's talents and so I do think it
reinforces the idea that women are
valued on their appearance and that's
who's going to win but I just think
think there's a lot of other components
of it that take away from how
superficial it might seem that make me
kind of disagree that it should be
discontinued I was just going to say
that I definitely agree with you guys's
sides as well my disagreement with it is
like the teen aspect and I didn't know
that they do activewear now because I
did have family members that used to be
in pageants and stuff like that where I
was like it's changed
over three years okay so then yeah I
might change my view then as well but I
think the over sexualization of like
teen girls is for me like I just don't
think that's right but what's
specifically about the team because I
feel like having a team that knows about
certain viewpoints whether it's what do
you think about social media or can you
talk about bullying I think that teens
deserve to have that representative as
well and then also it's like okay
there's makeup but teens also go to prom
so I think that without beauty pageants
you all just said you look at Billboards
and you compare yourself I don't think
that it will stop the comparison but I
also feel like it's it's not compared to
sports but it's very similar no one is
saying that we should get rid of sports
because men or women are comparing
themselves and in talent I definitely
understand the thing about um leadership
and just like having your own voice but
there are other ways that you can have
that voice that don't put such a high
emphasis on beauty it should be more
about who we are and I think while
beauty pageants aren't all about beauty
they're still named beauty pageants at
the end of the day it's still about
beauty
modeling is feminist
I mean I think it's a form of expression
and femininity and if you find comfort
in it and if you're expressing yourself
I think feminists can mean a lot of
different things I don't think there's
one way to be a feminist so it can be
different for anyone and if you're a
model and you also Define yourself as a
feminist it's possible that it can be
both I agree I think it's a great way
for people to express themselves and it
can give women a platform in some ways
and so I think that in itself is
feminist as like feminism kind of to me
gives like sort of equal representation
and so as modeling can be like a Gateway
for people to build their platforms and
their positions I think that's what
makes it feminist
foreign
I'm kind of like 50 50 between if it's
feminist or not feminist the male Vision
has been very implemented onto women and
sometimes I feel like it is overly
sexualized it's very sex cells that type
of vibe that's the only reason I feel
like it's not feminist per se I agree I
feel like the industry actually affects
women more negatively than men so I
wouldn't say that it's solely a feminist
you know power to the woman I feel like
we actually take a hit we have a lot of
negative things I think that we are
doing better and that we're improving
but I wouldn't say that this you know
industry has always just uplifted women
when you think of the modeling industry
the first thing you think of is skinny
people I'm sorry I'm just gonna say it
and there's not a lot of representation
for people who are medium-sized people
who are plus-sized and when we look at
the modeling industry we then feel less
than so it does more harm than good
because it only shows like
a little bit of the population I do
agree with what you were saying it's
true it's a very in a way elitist
industry that only incorporate a certain
body type and height and measurements
but also I would have to say that I see
more and more models who are plus size
there's a huge Market that's being open
to that there's never been more
inclusivity personally I think and now
it's really becoming more open yeah I
definitely agree with the fact that it's
getting more open but still when I look
at a billboard I see a skinny person all
that content still breeds a lot of
insecurities for girls who don't who
aren't that body type because the
default is still skinny
how I feel when I see skinny models is
definitely
um a sense of not jealousy but like
because I have a little more meat on my
bones will I be perceived as less than
will I have less opportunities and also
am I not healthy just because I am
bigger than
um a what a conventional model looks
like it does create a certain level of
insecurity because not all women or even
men for the fact not all of them are
represented but I will say that stepping
into the entertainment industry didn't
make me insecure I think it just
highlighted things that I was already
insecure about I'm like okay these
people are really skinny there's not a
lot of black women you know I think it
kind of just highlights things that we
already think about ourselves I think it
also depends on what type of modeling
you do I think there's some agencies
that are going to still to the state
tell you that you're too big or your
hips are too wide or you need to lose
weight here and here but it's not been
my experience I've been very body
positive I've never had somebody tell me
I need to lose weight or you need to do
this and this which has been very
comfortable for me the campaigns that I
see nowadays the people that I work with
has been a broad spectrum than it what I
feel like it has been in the maybe 10
years ago or so even I couldn't agree
more personally I think that more than
the modeling industry something that
really exacerbates these maybe
insecurities is social media it's like
going on your phone like any young child
can go on there and then compare
themselves to not necessarily models but
other women who put filters and that is
really something that is a bit more
dangerous nowadays I would say I have
suffered from eating disorders
starting at a pretty young age I was
worried about my weight covid kind of
cut off my sixth grade school year so I
was um I just turned 12 years old when
covet started and I started doing these
Chloe Tang workouts and then that kind
of turned into this over obsession with
working out every day or I was gonna get
fatter and it also turned into me not
really eating the proper amount I should
have been and I lost a substantial
amount of weight I lost my period for
about three months during this time as
well and now I look back at these times
and it was the worst I've ever been
feeling but it was the most anyone's
ever complimented me or said oh you look
so good or you look so skinny like you
look so much better than you did before
I think that's a very negative aspect of
when we see someone we comment on their
bodies even if it's oh you look so good
oh your body looks so good maybe they
could be struggling and then they're
gonna think oh I I need to stay this way
I need to stay and looked a certain way
and for me that's what happened and then
I realized I'm super unhealthy and I
could get even more unhealthy if I stay
this way so I I actually worked on body
self-acceptance and though I'm
definitely not there yet I that's what's
helped me so much is from support from
my parents and from my from my friends
who know I've gone through this
I would like to join what you were
saying I never suffered from eating
disorder but I remember being in Paris
and when I was in my skinniest my agents
and everybody around me in the industry
was like you look amazing and I was like
wow this is so wrong it's interesting
how people think because you're so
skinny like the happiest and you know it
is very something really wrong about
that and I totally understand that and I
also think as consumers we only get so
much of a glimpse into the modeling
industry like if I'm scrolling on Tick
Tock a lot of the times I see like what
I eat in a day videos as a model the
next day you go about your day you're
immediately comparing to how much you're
eating versus these models and so um
yeah I think disordered eating is just
kind of something that's extremely
prevalent with all women especially
growing up that's so true I think that
when you see the tick tocks of like what
I eat in a day you know I want to
challenge everyone to start looking at
ads differently because a lot of times
it's probably not actually promoting
what they're eating in a day it's
probably trying to sell the service I
think culture plays a large role in it
as well because in the modeling industry
of course be skinny be this size but for
me when I go home my grandmother is like
you need to like do you want me to cook
for you so I'm like okay I'm going home
and now I'm like too skinny you have no
idea how many people so how many people
tell models often like oh you probably
don't eat anything and I'm like oh here
we go again it's like so frustrating and
I'm like no actually do it really well
now I just joking I said no I haven't
eaten since um birth you know and they
they're like oh they're so shocked
because I'm like the comment is so like
rude you would never tell a person
that's a bit overweight oh you probably
eat so much French fries but it's easy
to sell a person oh you don't need
anything just because that person is
leaner and some of us are like just
naturally really skinny and we can eat
all we want and just we don't get put on
weight
I love my body
it's hard for me to completely agree
with the notion that I love my body just
because it's hard to say that you love
something that you battle with every day
and that you're constantly looking at
and overly criticizing to yourself but
your body is a part of you and it
doesn't matter how you look like at the
end of the day it comes down to what our
bodies provide for us and the
opportunities that it gives us and so I
think that the reason I say I love my
body isn't at all because of how it
looks but just because of what it gives
me and how grateful I am to be
able-bodied and to live life the way I
do so for me for instance it wasn't
always the case not that I hated it
before it was just I did have some
insecurities as a teenager and becoming
a model then also I exacerbated certain
of this insecurities of course but I
think there's a beautiful thing about
aging is personally for me I fully
accept myself the way I am I'm a mother
now I have a two-year-old daughter and
seeing the miracle of the body that can
create a human I will never again like
think oh the stretch mark that this and
I think acceptance is the most important
part about beauty that's also part of
personally for me aging
I have a two-year-old daughter and I
would not necessarily encourage my
daughter to become a model because I
think it's such a difficult industry
that I would not want my kid to do it
long term not as a career I would say
but just as a hobby it's an industry
that's really based on Rejection it can
be harmful to young women so if that's
the route she decides to go for it when
she's older I would help her along the
way however this is definitely not
something I would encourage her to do
knowing all the difficult size of the
industry there's so many great things
but it's also things that I would not
necessarily want someone I love to go
through for me it's definitely a battle
it's a day-to-day thing sometimes some
days I really love how I look some days
I don't I mean part of it is definitely
um
my queerness and being on the masculine
side a lot of people don't view me as a
girl and I get misgendered a lot and I
am definitely on the non-binary Spectrum
as well but I also feel very feminine a
lot of the time and I am still a woman
so it's about finding who I am finding
Myspace in Womanhood and like the other
day I looked in the mirror and I flexed
my muscles and I've been working out a
lot and I was like dang it's something
that all of us have to do to be to be
able to live a long healthy life is look
at ourselves and be like wow this is who
I am and I'm not just okay with that not
just accepting it but I'm happy with it
I think it's like a sibling you know
just because they do something one day
that you may not like or that you're
like wow I don't like you today but I
still love you and you're still my
brother or you're still my sister and so
I think that choosing to say I love my
body doesn't mean that we don't have
days where we're like I might would
change this or I might need to get up
and go to the gym today it's like a
roller coaster you know and it's a
roller coaster of emotions but overall I
think that it is safe to say that you
love your body
it's kind of hard for me sometimes to
say I love my body this is such a
comparison even between models and who
gets the job and who doesn't get the job
that you put a microscope on yourself
and you're like well maybe if I was
getting skinnier or if I had a little
more weight or far I didn't have this
little thing and you're comparing to all
these girls that are going into castings
with you which I think definitely has
had a little bit of a harmful effect on
me myself I would hope that one day I
can give myself enough self-love to have
those things go away but it's definitely
still something I struggle with to this
day yeah
I would love to say that I lost my body
but a lot of times when I'm looking in
the mirror I'm not loving what I'm
seeing and it's so hard to like really
appreciate what I have and when I was
what I was given but I have two moms I
go to an all-girl school I'm surrounded
by girls constantly so I'm always
comparing myself and I think that's
where a lot of my my self-love issues
come from and though I do appreciate my
body for all it does for me it's so hard
for me to say that I I love it because
that would be that would be a lie
pretty privilege exists
I think there's no denying that whenever
we look our best people perceivers a
different way like if I get out of the
house looking all dolled up and I go to
an event you'll get more attention
opportunities than if I go to the same
event just with no makeup just looking
like I just got out of bed obviously it
is a thing it does exist but I also hate
how a lot of times we're boxed in or
we're confined because of that I feel
like there's also a downside where you
actually be a little underestimated just
because you are considered to be pretty
yeah I've also seen a lot of people
who've lost a ton of weight and they say
that one of the biggest things was they
were so surprised at how differently
they were treated especially when it's a
lot of weight and also there was a study
that said that when men don't find a
woman attractive like they tune her out
you know like a lot of times you won't
be listened to but also on the other
side of it sometimes when they just see
you as this valuable object They Don't
Really value your opinion so I think it
kind of goes both ways some
opportunities you have to prove yourself
over and over more to prove that you
know just like this pretty person but
you know to some people like no I can
get that job and I'm also smart I can do
both yeah yeah I mean I can wear a tank
top and also be super smart like I love
science and math and if I want to feel
confident and if I want to wear
something that's going to make me feel
confident I don't want to be put into a
box of oh you're only like pretty or
you're only like sexy or hot and like I
don't want to be this object to people
so it's it's definitely this balance of
what do I want today because it's not
it's rarely feeling like people are
perceiving you as bold
I do agree as a concept pretty privilege
is definitely real I just I don't like
the term I feel like pretty privilege
isn't actually a privilege you have to
be perfect or a huge section of society
won't like you we are expected to be
pretty enough but not too pretty to seem
dumb we're expected to be smart but not
smart enough to make the guys feel
threatened so it's more dividing us as
women and scapegoating women who can't
actually help how they look thank you
guys so much it was just so nice to have
a conversation where um just of all
women that was such a such a healing
thing to do